una vida dura que podría estar a punto
de volverse aún más dura ya que la
amenaza de un break shit si me acuerdo
se avecina estos pescadores franceses
pronto podrían encontrarse aislados de
los peces británicos pasamos todos los
veranos en aguas británicas el 80% de
nuestra pesca de verano proviene de ella
aquí en verano no hay nada los
pescadores son pagados con base en sus
capturas el 40% de las ventas va para
ellos el 60% para el armador sí para el
primero de enero no hay un acuerdo de
break sheet tendrán que pescar en aguas
francesas y eso significa un desastre
económico vamos a compartir esa franja
de mar del sur con todos los europeos
los holandeses dos belgas será una
catástrofe nivel
pero para el reino unido estas
situaciones sólo un caso de lo que viene
las ricas aguas británicas fueron
sobreexplotadas durante décadas y a
medida que el tamaño de la captura de
los pescadores británicos se redujo
también lo hizo la industria es la mitad
del tamaño que tenía en 1900
75 la pesca se ha convertido en un
amargo punto de inflexión política a
pesar de representar una pequeña
fracción de la economía británica la
última propuesta de la unión europea
para calmar a westminster es dar al
reino unido el 18 por ciento de toda la
captura de los pescadores europeos pero
eso ha sido rechazado por gran bretaña
sin embargo también hay mucho en juego
para reino unido ya que el 80% de su
captura se exporta gran parte de ella a
la unión europea en caso de no llegar a
un acuerdo estas exportaciones estarían
sujetas a aranceles